der Machthunger moskauz im Baltikum
kennt man ihn ganz genau
es gibt nur einen Feind und das ist
Russland es ist also naiv zu glauben
dass Russland weit weg ist
das Baltikum erst seit gut 30 Jahren
unabhängig von der Sowjetunion
viele hier blicken auf Russland den
ehemaligen Besatzer wieder besonders
argwöhnisch
wir wären bereit mit der Waffe in der
Hand an die Front zu gehen den Feind zu
bekämpfen und die Heimat zu verteidigen
ihre Freiheit an ihrer Ostsee wollen die
beiden nie wieder verlieren
ich habe vor gar nichts Angst wenn die
Ukraine die Russen schlagen können dann
könnten wir das auch lass die kommen
alles wird gut
ich treffe Menschen in Estland Lettland
und Litauen
alle drei Länder mit direkter Grenze zu
Russland
und ich erlebe wie plötzlich wieder
düstere Erinnerungen hochkommen in die
Gegenwart der Balken
auf dem Weg zur estnischen Insel Huma
ursprüngliche Natur zu sowjetszeiten
aber gesperrt für Besucher weil
strategisch so wichtig eins Tor in den
Nordwesten aus Moskauer Sicht
auf Huma ein Ort an dem die Sowjet-Zeit
Gewalt sichtbar ist das Militärmuseum
mit alten Denkmälern die man seit
letztem Jahr abgebaut und hier verstaut
hat
die Sowjetunion hat Estland 1940 besetzt
also müssen wir immer noch den Truppen
die uns besetzt hatten die ihre erweisen
ich denke nein es war jetzt echt an der
Zeit
seit Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine lässt
Estland die Sowjet Monumente aus dem
öffentlichen Raum verschwinden Moskau
das ewige gefühlte
[Musik]
Lettland Finnland Schweden und wir sind
an der Ostsee mit Polen Deutschland
Dänemark sie alle sind Freunde es gibt
nur einen Feind und das ist Russland es
ist also naiv zu glauben dass Russland
weit weg ist
wegen des Kriegs in der Ukraine haben
sie einen Raum neu eingerichtet mit
krassen Elementen
das ist ein echtes Andenken aus der
bachmut-region das sind Teile einer
Uniform und der Helm von einem getöteten
russischen Soldaten
eine Uniform als Warnung vor der alten
Besatzungsmacht und ihrem neuen Krieg
ist eine sehr schreckliche Sache da gibt
es nichts Romantisches nichts Schönes
nichts ruhmreiches es ist ein höllisches
Gefühl wenn man sowas trägt allein
dieser Teil der Ausrüstung wiegt mehr
als 30 kg man muss Rennen man muss
schießen natürlich verstehe ich warum
die Ukrainer Rennen schießen und ihr
Land schützen aber warum tun die Russen
das ganze die ganze Idee dahinter ist so
idiotisch
völlig sinnlos was der russische Führer
davon sich gibt
ein ist auf der Insel aufgewachsen bei
ihm spüre ich die Tiefe Verachtung für
den einstigen Besatzer Russland
besonders stark
wir sind frei das ist wieder unser Land
das ist unser Meer also können wir frei
auf dem Meer fahren die Fischer können
den Fisch fangen wir können Segeln ohne
Beschränkungen durch irgendwelche
idiotischen Regeln oder idiotischen
Ideen die sich nie erfüllt haben warum
sollten wir so etwas befolgen
auch in der estnischen Hauptstadt haben
sie sowjetmonumente aus dem öffentlichen
Leben verbannt Tallinn die coole an der
Ostsee mittelalterliche Innenstadt aber
tallinn ist auch jung am Strand lernen
wir Matthias kennen mich interessiert ob
er und seine Freunde jemals darüber
nachgedacht haben zu gehen Russland ist
Nachbar
wir haben das unter uns Freunden
besprochen weil immer die Frage im Raum
steht ob Russland in die baltischen
Staaten kommt und wieder überfällt
die meisten von uns würden nicht
weglaufen wir wären bereit mit der Waffe
in der Hand an die Front zu gehen den
fein zu bekämpfen und die Heimat zu
verteidigen
Matthias ist 22 hat längst sein eigenes
Startup ein Ehrensache in Italien
Matthias entwickelt Online Spiele als
Werbeplattformen er könnte in London
oder Shanghai arbeiten aber er bleibt
jedes Mal wenn ich einen Monat oder
länger weg war habe ich gefühlt ich
vermisse etwas von Estland was auch
immer wir sagen über unser Land es ist
unser Zuhause und wir lieben es
voll digital unterwegs analog zum
Sängerfest
einst haben sich die drei baltischen
Länder mit Singen gegen die Sowjets
gestellt mit der singenden Revolution
gegen russische Panzer
das ist ein Sängerfest eine Party bringt
uns zusammen und bedeutet jedem
einzelnen ehesten sehr viel ein Muss im
Sommer
das hier ist keine spießige Folklore es
ist die Identität einer oft
fremdbestimmten kleine Nation
Generationen sollten damals statt ihrer
estnischen Lieder die sowjet-ideologie
feiern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Großvater war schon kursänger meine
Mutter hat getanzt und ich bin schon
seit 18 Jahren im Chor es ist Teil der
estnischen Kultur ein codiert
der wichtigste Tag im Talina Sommer und
dann das
auch das gehört zur Ostsee das Wetter
schlägt schlagartig um
wir sind jetzt klatschnass aber das
dämpft doch nicht unseren Spirit wir
sind trotzdem auf der Bühne und singen
unser Lied singen hört nie auf
[Musik]
die ersten ein kleines 1,3 Millionen
Volk an der Ostsee im Machtpoker der
Jahrhunderte oft fremdbestimmt
wir reisen nach Narva
hier wohnen die die früher ihr Weltbild
den ersten aufzwangen Narwa ist bis
heute die russischste Stadt Island nur
ein Fluss trennt hier beide Länder
das Lebensgefühl in der Stadt ist immer
noch russisch die Vorfahren zu
verwirrzeiten einst bewusst von Moskau
hier angesiedelt von hier aus ging ein
Video von Alina in den sozialen
Netzwerken viral mit Protest gegen Putin
mit Putin ist ein und das am 9
mai dem Tag des Sieges einen wichtigen
russischen Feiertag
ich habe mich mit Alina am Grenzfluss
verabredet auch sie hat russische
Wurzeln
es war verboten irgendwelche Poster
mitzubringen weil sie die Situation
ruhig halten wollten es ist wirklich
sehr gefährlich wenn sich die Leute hier
in Estland untereinander streiten
und so war alles was Russland oder die
Ukraine unterstützt verboten aber du
kannst ja nicht einfach jemanden ein
T-Shirt ausziehen richtig
während wir drehen regt sich hinter der
Kamera eine Passantin auf man solle die
Polizei wegen dieser
anti-putinpropaganda rufen doch vor der
Kamera verstummt sie und verschwindet
die russische Seite beschallte im Mai
von drüben die estnische mit einem
Konzert und Kreml Propaganda die in
Island gehört werden sollte viele der
Nachkommen der in Narbe angesiedelten
Russen verehren noch den starken Mann in
Moskau und verfolgen nur russische
Medien
ich war einfach sehr verärgert
weißt du sie machen da drüben ein
Konzert extra für uns auf unserer Seite
für unsere ethnische Seite das ist pure
Provokation es gibt dort dieses narrativ
dass die Leute hier bei uns im Grunde
eingeschränkt sind
für Touristen ist die Grenze zu wer
Familie hat auf beiden Seiten darf hin
und her
offen über den Krieg in der Ukraine
sprechen eigentlich ein Tabu in nah war
Alina tut es trotzdem
natürlich hoffe ich dass die Ukraine
gewinnt
aber gleichzeitig bin ich besorgt was
nach Putin kommt wer wird das sein
die letzten Nachrichten zu rigoring alle
waren aufgeregt wie eine große
Revolution sei es aus aber gleichzeitig
wolltest du ihn an der Macht sehen
auch wenn man spürt dass hier viel
russischer Geist weht wir sind immer
noch in Island
Alina nimmt uns mit in ihre Welt sie ist
Lehrerin nach dem Protest gegen Putin
legte ihr die Schulleitung nahen zu
kündigen die 22-Jährige fühlt sich als
Estin Punkt sie versucht mir dieses
russische trauern um die Vergangenheit
zu erklären
manchmal denke ich mir vielleicht war
das Leben für sie früher einfacher du
hattest eine Ideologie einen Job ein
Haus die gleichen Freunde aber jetzt ist
alles fragil und unsicher und du hast so
viel Auswahl du musst so viel Wissen und
kritisch denken das ist nicht mehr so
leicht
seit 1991 ist Estland wieder unabhängig
einst waren die Russen hier die
bestimmer jetzt sind sie nur noch die
Minderheit es gehen Risse durch Familien
auch durch die von Alina
ich sehe mich als erstes und ich liebe
meinen Vater klar wir haben
unterschiedliche politische Ansichten
wir haben verschiedene Meinungen zu
Identität ich glaube das regt vor allem
ihn auf und meine Mama sagt mir machst
du gut aber wir haben trotzdem eine gute
Beziehung
also ist er pro Putin
kein Problem für dich
nein wir haben hitzige Debatten manchmal
aber weißt du wann wir uns einig sein
werden wird die Zeit zeigen die Zeit
wird das sicherlich zeigen
Musiklehrerin Alina schreibt ihre
Gefühle in Lieder
[Musik]
sie wird Nava nach dem Sommer verlassen
nicht mehr ihre Welt sie geht in die
Hauptstadt Tallinn
[Musik]
zurück in ein ganz anderes Lebensgefühl
nach Huma der Insel ganz im Westen
Estlands früher für Besucher gesperrt
heute ein Hipster Hotspot
wir treffen Britt und Kathleen die
Freundinnen kommen aus der Hauptstadt
Tallinn sind aber im Herzen echte Huma
Mädels
immer am Wasser meist mit irgendeinem
Brett
der Wind will heute nicht surfen fällt
aus
sehr schade dass heute nicht der
richtige Tag ist aber diese Welle kann
man auch immer auftauchen hier an der
Ostsee wissen wir es nie im Voraus es
gibt keine Strömung man muss einfach
präsent sein
schaut euch doch das hier an sogar wenn
es keine Welle gibt schaut einfach in
mein Gesicht es ist trotzdem einfach
toll fantastisch
[Musik]
in Estland heißt die Ostsee Westsee
warum habe ich sie gefragt ihre Antwort
guck doch auf die Landkarte stimmt
natürlich das Meer im Westen des Landes
Britt und kettlin sind im Film und
eventbusiness beide verbringen den
Sommer mit ihren Familien hier
sie sind 39 und 42 waren Kinder als die
Sowjetunion zerfiel doch ihre Familien
kennen Russland noch als Besatzer ihres
Landes jetzt der russische Krieg gegen
die Ukraine es macht sie nachdenklich
man beginnt auch die eigenen Eltern
besser zu verstehen die ja unter dem
russischen Joch gelebt haben und warum
die ersten so sind in ihrem Wesen wie
viel äußere Einmischung wir hatten in
der Vergangenheit in unsere Identität
die Freiheit die wir seit 30 Jahren
haben erscheint für die jungen Leute so
selbstverständlich aber das kann man
ihnen nicht vorwerfen
für viele im Baltikum steht fest dass
Putin sie eigentlich wieder haben will
die NATO-Mitgliedschaft beruhigt dennoch
haben zuletzt viele ehesten Wohnungen im
Ausland gekauft viele weit weg im Westen
wie in Spanien
trotz der Spannungen ihre meiste Zeit
ist unbeschwert
[Musik]
an den Krieg hat man sich irgendwie
gewöhnt
[Musik]
die Leichtigkeit auf Huma wird besonders
deutlich an Tagen wie diesem die
Sonnenwende
es ist das Highlight des Jahres auf der
Insel auf mich machen die beiden den
Eindruck das Leben in Estland ist für
sie fast alternativlos
dieser magische Ort kalana hat uns hier
auf Yuma verankert
es wäre nicht allzu kompliziert mit
unseren Familien ins Ausland zu gehen
aber vorstellen kann ich es mir
eigentlich nicht
dass ich Freunde und Familie verlassen
müsste das ist nicht so leicht
aber der Gedanke war natürlich da
besonders intensiv in den ersten Tagen
nach dem 24 Februar
mit der Familie hatten wir schon einen
Plan
weltoffen aber immer sehr
heimatverbunden so erlebe ich die ersten
seit Jahren weil ihre Heimat ihnen immer
wieder gestohlen wurde
[Musik]
von Estland reisen wir weiter nach
Lettland
Russlands macht Anspruch bestimmte auch
hier das Leben der Menschen
der alte Kriegshafen von karoster mit
seinem ausgedienten Militärgefängnis für
sowjetische Marine Soldaten
auch heute kann man sich hier anschreien
lassen wenn man dafür zahlt
noch was interessantes wo die Füße und
da sind wir
mein Mann hat mir das zum Geburtstag
geschenkt
romantisches Wochenende
Dieter und Jannis sind aus der Nähe von
Riga Antreten zur extrem-tour ab 50 Euro
alles aufsammeln alles
alle werden bestraft wenn einer ein
Idiot ist wie gerade Thomas
einmal sich fühlen wie ein straffälliger
Sowjet Matrose damals
kannst du jetzt atmen
jetzt
siehst du es funktioniert
[Musik]
Einchecken im Militär Knast gehorsam ist
oberstes Gebot die Truppe ist sofort
tief drin im Spiel wie Jannis ist okay
interessant
die Geschichten die uns erzählt hat das
hat mich echt nachdenklich gemacht über
unsere dunklen Zeiten der Geschichte
keine Fragen angespannte Stimmung nicht
zerstören klare Ansage an mich nach
einer Stunde traue ich mich vorsichtig
wozu das Ganze um Himmels willen
zu beantworten denn seit letztem Jahr
seit Februar 2022 haben viele Kollegen
ihre Uniform geändert
von sowjetisch zu neutral
weil wir mit beiden Regimen Russisch und
sowjetisch nichts zu tun haben wollen in
diesem Teil schon gar nicht
glorifizieren aber die Geschichte zeigen
das kann man sich doch viel besser
merken mit so einer Erfahrung geben
das war ziemlich genau das was gerade in
der Ukraine passiert
[Musik]
wir verstehen sie wir helfen Ihnen so
gut es geht
drei Stunden Drill Bleisch wäre Munition
transportieren die Zeit zieht sich
man leidet mit
[Musik]
das war eine echt interessante Übung wir
mussten diese Granate tragen die ist
extrem schwer so etwa 40 Kilo
das war bestimmt Absicht nur zwei von
uns haben das geschafft da habe ich
gefühlt es wurde mir klar wie schwierig
das für die Soldaten in der Ukraine ist
ihr Land zu verteidigen extrem schwierig
die Drangsalierung geht weiter
eigentlich bin ich nur Beobachterin doch
dann die Anweisungen mich ran an die
Wand
ich tue es komme da nicht raus
funktioniere ein wirklich merkwürdiges
Gefühl
der nächste Morgen es ist vorbei die
Nacht auf dem Holzbrett wirkt spürbar
nach
wie war die Nacht
das war jetzt nicht wie im Hotel keine
frische Luft Schimmel überall und dann
diese Art Bett aber ich habe es
geschafft
definitiv ich kann es jedem nur
empfehlen
wir alle haben Angst
das ist ein kollektives Trauma für alle
post sowjetsstaaten
[Musik]
und
tief in uns drinnen haben wir Angst dass
das noch mal passieren könnte
muss man so etwas wirklich gemacht haben
ist das schräg zynisch oder eben gerade
nicht weil es hilft die aktuelle Lage
besser zu verstehen eine Antwort finde
ich so schnell nicht was ich aber
mitnehme die Bedrohung durch den alten
Besatzer ist durchaus wieder ein Thema
in Lettland die einen spielen Knast die
anderen wollen genau dem entgehen Rieger
ist zu Exil geworden für viele russische
Journalisten die sich zu Hause nicht
mehr sicher fühlten
wir haben vor dem Krieg Praktika im
Ausland absolviert und wir haben früher
Publikationen veröffentlicht die von
internationalen journalistischen Fonds
finanziert wurden deshalb hätten wir als
ausländische Agenten gelten können
und natürlich unterstützen wir nicht den
Krieg
am Wochenende treffen sich Elena und
andere russische exiljournalisten zu
Entspannungsübungen an der Ostsee
anders als Helena meiden viele unsere
Kamera aus Sorge vor dem langen Arm
Moskau
[Musik]
als mein Land in die Ukraine
einmarschierte hielt ich es für
unethisch in meiner Heimat zu bleiben
weil ich die Politik der Regierung nicht
unterstütze und keine Möglichkeit fand
erfolgreich zu protestieren deshalb bin
ich mit meiner Familie gegangen
Jelena schreibt für eine lettische
russischsprachige Zeit eine Rückkehr in
ihr altes Leben zu riskant und obwohl
die Ostsee sie an zu Hause erinnert sie
vermisst St Petersburg
auf jeden Fall will ich meine Mutter
besuchen meine Verwandten sehen ich
hoffe wirklich dass das bald vorbei ist
auch wenn das niemand mit Sicherheit
sagen kann
Zufluchtsort Riga wir treffen die
Schauspielerin tulpanka matowa in
Deutschland bekannt aus dem Film goodbye
lening sie war im Ausland als ihr Land
die Ukraine über viel und kehrte nicht
mehr nach Russland zurück holte auch die
Töchter von Moskau nach Rieger nach
ich habe meine Zukunft verloren
alle Pläne als Schauspielerin alle Pläne
für Wohltätigkeit sind innerhalb eines
Tages verschwunden
sie kritisiert den russischen
Imperialismus sie sagt und Sie können
nicht still sein würde am liebsten ihre
Meinung laut in Moskau sagen
lebensgefährlich bei einer Person des
öffentlichen Lebens in Riga ist das
möglich
das ist Selbstmord für Russland
keine Zukunft mehr gibt
Putin und seine Freunde haben die
Zukunft des Landes weggenommen
von Moskau entfernt die Nähe ihre
Popularität machen sie zur möglichen
Zielscheibe
[Musik]
zurück auf dem Stützpunkt der Sowjets an
der Ostsee in Lettland
der alte Wasserturm des militärhafens
die alte Funktion ist vorbei hier
arbeiten nun Künstler wie der Lette
Egons
Egons war erst 9 als Lettland unabhängig
wurde von der Sowjetunion
[Musik]
wenn ich auf die Sowjetunion Blicke ist
sie langweilig und grau
heute wird alles farbenfroher
interessanter diverse offener
Freiheit ist für mich das Wichtigste
das war etwas das inservierzeiten eben
nicht da war
[Musik]
zeitgenössische lettische Kunst mitten
in einem Viertel das früher gesperrt war
nur Angehörige der Militärs durften rein
heute leben noch viele der von Moskau
hier angesiedelten russischen Familien
Egons will hier mittendrin mit seiner
Kunst die Kulturen in Kontakt bringen
verbinden und doch spüre ich für wen
sein lettisches Herz schlägt in
Kriegszeiten
ich fühle mit ihnen vor allem mit den
Ukrainern
sie leiden immer noch am meisten
wir sind der Sowjetunion entkommen
ziemlich schnell
der Turm war strategisch wichtig für die
Wasserversorgung von carosta in
sowjetszeiten heute Kunst damals scharf
bewacht
Egons zeigt mir wo sich Matrosen in der
Wand verewigten
das hier ist von 85
es gibt auch ältere siehst du von 56
ist es wichtig diese Dinge zu bewahren
ich weiß es nicht so ist das Leben Dinge
erscheinen Dinge verschwinden
5 Jahrzehnte so wird Herrschaft in
Lettland
mai 1950 hier war eine bachstation Leute
haben einfach was eingeritzt wenn sie
hier zu Tode gelangweilt waren
vor allem jüngere Letten so wie Egons
arbeiten nun bewusst auf dem
ex-militärgelände bringen neues Leben
[Musik]
in Litauen fahren wir entlang der
Kurischen Nehrung direkt an der Grenze
zu Kaliningrad eine Halbinsel mit
Bilderbuchlandschaft ein Teil gehört zu
Litauen der andere zu Russland am Steuer
soteras hier aufgewachsen er hat schon
als Kind Deutsch gelernt wegen der
Touristen
Russland den früheren Besatzer hat er
immer im Blick Putin hat den Verlust der
baltischen Republiken nie verschmerzt
wenn die kommen die kommen was kann ich
machen ich kann nur alles mitpacken und
z.B nach Deutschland fahren weil ich
kann besser deutsch als Englisch das
war's
so TERAs bietet Bootstouren an
es verdrängen entschieden so mein
Eindruck meidet Nachrichten
und diese ganze newswürdigkeit gar nicht
so viel wir hören ne ich will nur hören
wenn die Ukraine gewinnt dann gucke ich
wieder nicht aber jetzt
auf dem Festland liegt die Stadt
Klaipeda
beschaulich mit einem malerischen
Bootshafen und Altstadt
aber Klaipeda ist auch strategisch
bedeutend für Litauen hier ist der
wichtigste Frachthafen des Landes dort
gibt es auch ein lng-terminal yogita ist
die handelschefin des Terminals sie
nimmt uns dahin mit
die Drehgenehmigung hat gedauert
kritische Infrastruktur die in diesen
Zeiten noch schärfer geschützt wird zum
Beispiel ist die Marine hier verstärkt
im Einsatz
haben viele zusätzliche
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergriffen zum
Beispiel werden LNG schiffslieferungen
eskortiert
man hat also diesen Nachbarn der groß
ist und manchmal Energie macht politisch
nutzt gegen Nachbarländern
Cyberangriff auf Ihre Firma habe es
längst gegeben sagt mir yogita das
lng-terminal seit 2014 in Betrieb
independence der Name ist Programm
davor war Litauen abhängig von
russischem Gas misstraute Moskau aber
früh und setzte stattdessen auf
internationales LNG
Litauen warnte stets vor der
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas war
scharfer Kritiker von Nord Stream 2 und
damit vom deutschen Weg
litauen ist sehr nah an Russland trotz
des Fakt dass wir nicht eine sehr lange
Grenze mit Russland haben aber wir haben
die Grenze zur Exklave Kaliningrad und
auch die Grenze zu Belarus das sehr eng
mit Russland verbunden ist so vor allem
gerade jetzt
für uns in der Nachbarschaft dieser
Länder bringt es die Grenze zur Ukraine
sehr nah auch zu unseren Grenzen
Russland auf der einen Seite westliche
Partner auf der anderen
die Ausrichtung Litauens ist klar
yogita spricht für das lng-terminal aber
die große Mehrheit in Litauen teilt ihre
Meinung
the first impressions
der erste Eindruck ist dass wir die
Ostsee mit allen Ländern drumherum
Teilen
etwas was uns vereint für Kooperationen
zum Beispiel
und jetzt mit Finnland in der NATO sind
fast alle ostseestaaten in der NATO
country
gegen die gemeinsame Bedrohung direkt an
der Grenze
im Bootshafen von Klaipeda kommen gerade
Fischer Wirges und seine Jungs von der
Ostsee zurück die russischen Fanggebiete
immer vor der Nase
[Musik]
seit dem Krieg ist es hier nicht mehr so
ruhig beide Seiten überwachen Ihre
Grenzen schärfer die litauische Marine
begegnet ihnen jetzt öfters
Drohnen Flugzeuge Helikopter mehr
Schiffe wir sehen da echt viel davon
vor gar nichts sagst wenn die Ukraine
die Russen schlagen können dann könnten
wir das auch lass die nur kommen alles
wird gut
kämpfen für die Heimat sagen Sie mir
aber klar doch jederzeit
die Fischerei ein Knochenjob aber ihr
Lebenselixier
die Ostsee ist einfach mein Zuhause ich
bin hier aufgewachsen ich arbeite schon
30 Jahre hier jetzt fängt auch mein Sohn
hier an es bedeutet mir alles wir sind
ein maritimes Land für die Leute in
Klaipeda bedeutet die sie alles
und seine Jungs laden uns in ihre
Fischhalle ein sie sind stolz auf den
Job und ihr Litauen Sohn Paulus wird im
Fall der Fälle der Heimatarmee beitreten
die boomt in Litauen mit nicht nur bei
Waffen machen bei Vater wirklich spürt
man jeder balte trägt seine
Familiengeschichte und die Erfahrung mit
Moskau im Herzen
meine Großeltern wurden nach Sibirien
verschleppt und deren Großeltern wurden
woanders hingebracht vielleicht auch
getötet weißt du wo immer die Russen
auftauchen haben sie nichts Gutes
hinterlassen meine gesamte Familie wurde
deportiert also die Ukraine machen
gerade ihren Job für uns alle nicht nur
für sich so denke ich einfach
paulus hat einen ingenieurabschluss
Zeitverschwendung nennt er es er will an
und auf der ostseearbeiten die Tradition
waren das Land die Werte verteidigen und
die Freiheit an ihrer Ostsee nicht nur
einmal verlieren das eint die Menschen
im Baltikum
der Macht poke an der Ostsee ist nicht
nur im Baltikum ein Thema mein Kollege
Gunnar Krüger hat Soldaten der NATO
begleitet und berichtet wie das Bündnis
den Ostseeraum schützen will mit ihnen
Tauchern und abfangen Jägern und die
ganze Dokumentation zu sehen in der ZDF
Mediathek